supongamos que tenemos una solución de
ácido acético
sabemos que el ácido acético en solución
dona un protón al h2o para formar h 3 o
más y la base conjugada del ácido
acético
es decir el acetato de h3c o menos
entonces tenemos una concentración de
aniones acetato en solución pero qué
pasa si agregamos un poco de acetato de
sodio bueno si agregamos un poco de
acetato de sodio h3c o menos enea más a
la solución al agregar más acetato
estamos aumentando la concentración de
iones acetato y de acuerdo al principio
de lecha tellier si aumentamos la
concentración de uno de los productos el
equilibrio cambia hacia la izquierda y
eso significa que algunos años es
acetato reaccionarán con algunos iones
hidronew y eso disminuye la
concentración de iones y drones y al
disminuir la concentración de iones
sidronio aumenta el ph de la solución
así que el acetato de sodio sería el ión
común y este es el efecto de lyon común
entonces aquí hay dos fuentes de iones
acetato una fuente es la ionización de
ácido acético y la otra fuente es el
acetato de sodio que nosotros agregamos
esas son las dos fuentes y esperaríamos
que el ph sea mayor al de la solución en
donde sólo había ácido acético vamos a
hacer un cálculo y comprobemos eso vamos
a calcular el ph de una solución que
tiene una concentración 1 molar de ácido
acético también nos dan el valor de caja
para el ácido acético y vamos a agregar
una solución 1 molar t acetato de sodio
entonces vamos a empezar por escribir la
reacción ácido base tenemos ácido
acético más agua
es una reacción que está en equilibrio
con los productos y nuestros productos
son h 3 o más y los anones acetato de
h3c o menos supongamos que sólo tenemos
ácido acético entonces al inicio la
concentración de ácido acético es 1
molar y en el cambio perdemos una cierta
concentración de ácido acético que
ganamos de añón es acetato y de iones
hidronew entonces ganamos una cierta
concentración de acetato pero nos falta
agregar algo observen que tenemos una
concentración 1 molar de acetato de
sodio que como ya dijimos es otra fuente
de añón es acetato entonces vamos a
escribirla recuerden la concentración de
añón es acetato proviene de dos fuentes
de la ionización del ácido acético y del
acetato de sodio que agregamos nosotros
a la solución entonces las
concentraciones iniciales nos
un homme olarte ácido acético 1 molar de
aniones acetato y prácticamente cero de
iones y drone ya vamos con el equilibrio
al equilibrio nos queda 1 - x en el
ácido acético x de iones hidronew y uno
mas x de aniones acetato o que
escribamos la expresión de equilibrio
vamos a escribir acá
porque inicialmente tenemos ácido
acético que dona un protón al agua
entonces acá
es igual a la concentración de los
productos entre la de los reactivos
tenemos concentración de h3 o más por la
concentración de uniones acetato y todo
eso entre la concentración de los
reactivos recuerden sin tomar en cuenta
el agua así que nos queda la
concentración de ese h3c
h ok entonces la concentración de idron
yo al equilibrio es x x por la
concentración de acetato al equilibrio
que es uno más x 1.00 + x entre la
concentración de ácido acético que es 1
- x entonces entre 1.00 menos x
podemos suponer que la concentración x
es mucho más pequeña que 1 así podemos
decir que uno menos x es prácticamente
igual a 1 y también uno más x es igual a
entonces como esta es una concentración
muy pequeña
podemos decir que uno más x es igual a 1
voy a describirlo nos queda x x 1 x que
es aproximadamente igual a 1 entre 1 - x
que también es aproximadamente igual
a uno y todo esto es igual al valor de
cada que para el ácido acético es igual
a 1.8 por 10 a la menos 5 ahora los unos
se cancelan y nos queda que la
concentración de iones sidronio x x
representa la concentración de iones
hidronew es igual a 1.8 por 10 a la
menos 5 y finalmente para calcular el ph
sólo tenemos que calcular el menos
logaritmo de esto entonces menos
logaritmo de 1.8 por 10 a la menos 5
usemos la calculadora menos logaritmo de
1.8 por 10 a la menos 5 es igual a 4.74
y el ph es igual a 4 puntos 74
en el vídeo sobre el equilibrio de una
base débil calculamos el ph de una
solución 1 molar de ácido acético y ahí
obtuvimos un ph igual a 2.38 pero no
teníamos otra fuente de angelis acetato
como en este caso por eso aquí el ph es
más alto porque acuérdense tenemos dos
fuentes de an iones acetato la
ionización del ácido acético y la
adición de acetato de sodio hagamos otro
problema del efecto de unión común
esta vez necesitamos calcular el ph de
una solución 0.15 molar de amoniaco y
0.35 molar de nitrato de amonio que en
solución se disocia en nh 4 más y n o 3
- empecemos con el amoniaco escribamos
lo que sucede cuando el amoniaco
reacciona con el agua el amoniaco es una
base débil y tomará un protón del agua
entonces 100
h 3 toma unas yemas formamos nh 4 +
amonio y como le quitamos un protón al
h2o nos queda o h menos el ión hidróxido
ahora al inicio sólo tomando en cuenta
el amoniaco tenemos una concentración
inicial 0.15 molar 0.15 y en el cambio
la misma concentración de amoniaco que
perdemos la ganamos de amonio ya que el
amoniaco se transforma en amonio y por
lo tanto ganamos la misma concentración
de hidróxido entonces una fuente de
iones amonio sería la protón acción de
amoniaco pero tenemos una segunda fuente
porque agregamos una solución 0.35 molar
de nitrato de amonio así que al inicio
también tenemos una concentración 0.35
molar de amonio
0.35 y podemos decir que la
concentración inicial de hidróxido es
ser ahora cuando la reacción llega al
equilibrio de amoniaco tenemos 0.15
x de amonio como tenemos dos fuentes al
final nos queda 0.35 x y de hidróxido x
entonces como el amoniaco actúa como una
base débil vamos a escribir la expresión
de equilibrio cab de que para el
amoniaco es igual a 1.8 por 10 a la
menos 5 y esto es igual a la
concentración de los productos entre la
de los reactivos aquí tenemos la
concentración de nh 4 más por la
concentración de o h - y todo esto nos
queda entre la concentración de los
reactivos pero sin tomar en cuenta el
agua así que sólo nos queda amoniaco
la concentración de nh 3 ok ahora
hagamos la sustitución la concentración
de amonio es 0.35 x 0.35 x después la
concentración de hidróxido es x x y todo
esto entre la concentración de amoniaco
al equilibrio que es igual a 0.15
x entonces 0.15
x y ya sabemos que cabe es igual a 1.8
por 10 a la menos cinco entonces 1.8 por
10 a la menos 5 es igual a bueno
nuevamente supongamos que x es un número
muy pequeño así es más fácil entonces
nos queda que esto es igual a 0.35
porque podemos decir que 0.35 más x es
aproximadamente 0.35 y luego tenemos por
equis esta x corresponde a esta y todo
esto entre nuevamente 0.15
x cuando x es un número muy pequeño es
aproximadamente igual a 0.15 ahí está
calculemos el valor de x usemos la
calculadora tenemos 1.8 por 10 a la
menos 5 x 0.15 / 0.35 y esto es igual a
7.7 por 10 a la menos 6 entonces x es
igual a 7.7 por 10 a la menos 6 y x
representa la concentración de iones
hidróxido en la solución entonces esta
es la concentración molar de iones
hidróxido
ahora el problema nos pide que
calculemos el ph como nosotros ya
conocemos la concentración de iones
hidróxido podemos calcular el ph que es
igual a menos el logaritmo de la
concentración de iones hidróxido 7.7 por
10 a la menos 6 usemos la calculadora
menos logaritmo de 7.7 por 10 a la menos
6 es igual a 5.11 el ph es igual a 5.11
y sabemos que ph ph es igual a 14 así
que simplemente sustituimos el ph y nos
queda que ph es igual a 14 menos 5.11 y
eso es igual a 8.89 este es el ph de la
solución